if you look at our history I think what
will happen is that will change in all
sorts of serious important ways and we
won't notice it because what always
happens is that the day before you're
born is always eaten and the things that
happen to you in your own life span are
always technology and the day after your
children are born is always mad max'
right so we always are in the situation
where we think that the things that
happen to us are technological
innovations and they're probably going
to end up being Mad Max but then of
course if we think about the things like
the fact that in this room there are
right angles everywhere it's not like
we're really sitting there saying my god
the right angles the right angles are
kicking over everywhere even though the
fact of right angles has made enormous
changes in our lives so the fact that
there's print everywhere doesn't strike
us as being something that's is weird
technology that we're constantly getting
distracted because we have to figure out
what that R is right that's just that's
just part of our lives and I suspect
what will happen is will change in
really deep and profound ways and we
won't notice it because it'll be
happening over and across generation
that's fantastic
[Applause]
[Music]